in the Chinese city where the corona
virus outbreak started
health officials say there's been a drop
in new cases for the first time in six
weeks it's closing one of Wuhan 60 new
hospitals that were built in January to
cope with the increase in patients but
kovat 19 continues to spread elsewhere
the World Health Organization says nine
times as many cases were reported
outside China within 24 hours it says
the best defense is still containment we
are in unchartered territory
we have never seen before this
respiratory pathogen that's capable of
community transmission but at the same
time which can also be contained with
the right measures the three countries
worst affected outside China or South
Korea Iran and Italy Rome is preparing a
stimulus program to help the country's
economy in Venice the canals which are
usually packed with tourists are
deserted
Italy's tourism board reports more than
90 percent of travel bookings have been
cancelled in the capital scientists in
the United States are racing towards
finding a vaccine President Donald Trump
told pharmaceutical bosses he wants
results within months today we're
meeting with the pharmaceutical and
biotechnology companies the biggest in
the world most prestigious the ones that
get down to and the bottom line very
quickly to discuss how the federal
government can accelerate the
development of vaccines and therapeutic
treatments for the coronavirus US
scientists say the rollout of a corona
virus vaccine is at best a year and a
half away
Victoria Gaytan B al-jazeera